the u.s. is determined to stop another
security breach pro-iranian protesters
were forced to disperse after US troops
fired tear gas the demonstrators who
camped overnight outside the American
Embassy in Baghdad say they will only
leave on one condition we are here
holding a sit-in for the souls of our
martyrs until the departure of the
American occupiers they've committed
aggression at our borders against our
army and our sacred forces this small
act is for the martyrs so many of us
were killed this is not the first time
that the US has hit us we were bombed
before we will never move from here I
swear on God and on my life until they
leave here protestors are outraged over
US airstrikes in Iraq and Syria that
killed more than a dozen Hezbollah
fighters the retaliation came after the
militia group killed an American citizen
on Wednesday a u.s. Rapid Response Team
arrived in Baghdad President Donald
Trump who accused Iran of orchestrating
the attacks said the situation is now
under control
well I think it's been handled very well
the Marines came in we had some great
warriors come in
do a fantastic job and they were there
instantaneously as soon as we heard
I used the word immediately they came
immediately and it's in great shape as
you know Tuesday's attack was one of the
worst on a u.s. diplomatic mission in
years it has also raised questions again
about the future of American troops in
Iraq
[Music]